[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
make way for uh the fastest man in the
world he's usain bolt who joins us from
jamaica
last time i had you on i gave you an
idea fantasy camp where
people could come in and race you in the
100 meter dash and you could charge them
5 000 10 000
did you ever take me up on this great
business idea
no i didn't no i didn't
no i didn't
i mean you got thousands of people who
run want to run pay that kind of money i
mean all you got to do is run like 11
seconds or something
like you can coast
right
yeah it's true it's true but
for me it was
it was all up to the the i want to blame
i'm going to put that one on my manager
how how often do people come up and say
let's let's run let's race all the time
all the time like that's that's a
90 of the time the first thing people
say is like yo let's race let's go i
think i can take you
that's their first go-to
did you ever race anybody
i've i've raced a few kids just to put a
smile on their face with like nobody
else
are you still the fastest man in the
world
um yeah definitely without a doubt how
tough was it to watch the olympics
when it comes to the track and field
it was it was tough to see especially
because uh my fellow jamaican like male
sprinters weren't doing well
so for me it was it was really tough to
just watch and sit at home and
not be able to even say something to
them or talk to them or anything so it
was
it was pretty rough
michael phelps talked about his heart
started beating a little faster when he
was watching the swimming like what what
is did does your heart change when they
get to the
you know their starting line and you
know that gun's going to go off what's
that do to you i get very nervous i'm
i'm a nervous wreck when when i watch
people compete
when i'm competing i'm fine but
when i watch even 100 meter finals i i
didn't i wasn't supporting anybody
really but i was still nervous
watching it you know i mean so for me i
can't like watching competition is rough
for me but when i compete it's fine
what's the strangest thing you ever
thought of when you're in the starting
blocks
i don't know
like do you have music in your head or
like try to how do you clear everything
out i try to think about writing like in
the starting blocks you gotta clear try
to clear your mind as clear as possible
like when it comes to like standing
behind the blocks i think about random
stuff like i'll think about
if i'm gonna go out after
after or
am i gonna play video games or
what might i get for for dinner or
something i try to think about random
stuff like anything i just think about
random stuff before
i go on my marks when i get into the
blocks you have to try to clear your
mind what about when you're running the
race
running the race i'm just looking i
might look i just look around you know i
mean i tend to look around and see where
i'm at but i'm not really thinking about
anything i'm just trying to get to the
finish line
how close were you to coming back
i
i wasn't really close but i asked my
coach i said to my coaches i feel like
we should we should give it a shot
and he goes nope i told you
when you retired that's it and that's
what he said he told me like you know
when you retire
that's it i'm not gonna
come back i'm not doing a comeback tour
like anybody else this is it when you
retire you make up your mind to retire
that's it nothing else yeah but aren't
you in charge
yeah but he's the best and he told me
he's not going to coach me so i
can't i can't force him to coach me you
know he's like nope i'm not coaching
himself you come back i'm not doing it i
don't know if it'd be that hard to coach
you i might be able to do that you see
[Laughter]
right i think you could still run what
do you think you could run right now
what are you 35
yeah i'm 35 in a couple like a week okay
so um if i gave you two months to get
ready how fast do we run
i don't know probably 10-1
maybe okay
yeah
i mean i'm going to be pushing for 9 9.
definitely if i got if i got time i
still got speed if i got time to get
my my core ready and everything i'll be
alright all right let's go through the
names of the kids you got your daughter
olympia lightning bolt you got st leo
yeah and then you got thunderbolt yeah
okay what's mom say when
you
are you bringing up thunder are you
bringing up
lightning for me um
when when we when we had olympia first
we
the rule was if it was a girl she would
pick the name it's a boy outfit name so
that's she got the name um olympia and
then when the boys came i was like all
right here we go
i mean yeah
so that's that's how the names worked
out
but but but thunder bolt i mean i hope
he's fast
[Music]
that's what everybody says and he's full
of energy so that's a good sign so far
he's the one that cries a lot and he's
the one that will keep you up at night
so that's a very good sign so far you
know i mean that he's full of energy and
ready to go and but st leo
your middle name is
is leo
yeah okay i wanted a junior but i was
like you know what if i
give one my name then the other one's
going to be upset so i like you know i
just
give him half my name
i was wondering if you i think you love
cricket growing up you love soccer but
if you would it stuck to one of those
sports
like
what kind of
cricket
i think i would be really good at
cricket because i was good at a young
age and i really loved it because my dad
is a huge cricket fan
so i was always something even when i
got to high school
i still wanted to do it i would try to
train with the guys and then the coach
had to stop me like no you have to do
track and field you can't play cricket
this is what you're here for this is
what you're gonna do so
this cricket was something that i really
loved and i i knew i would be pretty
good at it
when did you become such a big football
fan american football
um
for me it was just one day because we
didn't get a lot of challenges challenge
uh channels back where i'm from we
didn't have cable and stuff it was like
two stations you know i mean
and just one day i'm watching
on tv and they the first game it was i
can't remember the packers against who
and i was like you know what
i like the packers they're pretty good
and that's how i really started to
support the packers and then when i came
to kingston we had a lot more chat
channels and then we could watch
more games and i started getting into it
year after year and i
and then mit my friends were big
football fans
my best friend is a giant fan so that's
how i really got more and more into
football but the packers colors are
similar to jamaica's colors did that
impact anything here oh no no no
just like soccer my my i support
manchester united was just the first
game i actually saw
and
they were pretty good and i was like you
know what i'm gonna support this team
and that's how it started
and when did you did you meet aaron
rodgers yet
no no i'm looking forward to it i wanted
them to get if they made it to the super
bowl last year i would have been there
and i would have met him
yeah how do you think you would do as a
wide receiver
um
i think i'm pretty good i think i have
good hands because i use i i usually i
normally i play qriket back in the day
so i think i have good hands i have
speed
it's just running the routes
i don't know maybe maybe not
well how are you when you get hit though
that's the key well it's it's all about
i think it's all about the the
physicality if if i work out i'm pretty
strong i'm pretty tall so i'm solid so i
think i could manage are we
this tyrique hill
you know uh challenge is that is that
ever going to happen and i i i have
something here for you i don't know i
don't know it's something that i've
thought about you know but i was like uh
should should i should i not how about
this
he wants 40
yeah you want a hundred yeah how about
70
i'm good i'm good with centimeters
because i think he'll take you in 40
yeah but he's not going to take
if he doesn't have you after 60 then
then he it's over yeah right
i still don't think he can take me 40
meters
even if he gets there it's going to be
really close
not
distances available he's gonna get out
there quick man yeah but but i proved
i'll prove if i could get in shape i
proved already that if i really like
warm up
and get ready to go i can run fast you
know i mean okay this is what i'm
suggesting the stakes are okay
a week after the super bowl or it could
be the super bowl weekend if he's not
playing
you put up one of your gold medals yeah
and he puts up his super bowl ring
nice there we
go that would be big
yeah cause you got what eight gold
medals yeah a guy
he's only got one super bowl ring
would he be willing
i don't think he's gonna go for it
well if he's not afraid
yeah i need to he's been talking so
we'll see yeah i would like to think
about it that we should put some
thoughts into that one yeah yeah you let
me handle it i got this
pay-per-view you're in on this right you
want a piece of tyra kill
yeah i said it to him i've texted him i
was like you keep talking i might just
show up
hey it's good to see you i hope you're
doing well and uh thanks for joining us
as always
no problem man it was a pleasure that's
usain bolt